Je suis ici au sommet de l'avion, semble-t-il
C'est quoi ce temps de morceaux sauf un
une heure et demie n'a pas d'interdiction sur le mien
et ils vont envoyer un poulet me chercher parce que
Ils ne me trouveront pas mais ils savent
papa
[Musique]
Yo
j'aimerais que tu le trouves
mais la dernière chose que tout le monde s'est dit
c'était juste que le
communication quand ils pensaient passer le
rivière
[Musique]
et
normale
[Musique]
Salut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
C'est un plaisir que nous soyons machinistes
trois ont bien défendu le plus grand donateur
montre que le début
[Musique]
Oh
et une journée ensoleillée
[Musique]
Dimanche sur YouTube, j'ai parlé avec elle
et
J'étais très heureux que cela arrive
y retourner dans un autre club
Plus grand que
que tu as aimé fonctionnait bien
bien
[Musique]
Non